[Music]
nfts even if you don't know what
non-fungible tokens are and i will get
to that you've probably seen talk of
them floating around the internet and
now
nfts are coming for cars
tonale is the first car ever equipped a
blockchain not fungible token yep the
new alfa romeo tanale suv will come with
its own nft but we're not talking about
some kind of collectible digital artwork
of the car so how could the auto
industry use blockchain technology and
are car nfts a passing fad or here to
stay let's find out
[Music]
okay first what is an nft the super
simplified version is that a
non-fungible token is basically a unique
one-of-a-kind certificate that can store
information the important part is that
token can be authenticated using the
blockchain a decentralized network of
computers that no one person owns but
anyone can access that can verify or
disprove that a token is what it claims
to be
famously nfts have been used as proof of
ownership of the original of an easily
replicated digital collectible take this
board api club site that sells images of
yep board apes for literally hundreds of
thousands of dollars now while there is
absolutely nothing stopping me from
downloading this image i'd just be
downloading a copy the nft is used to
say who has the original like a
certificate that comes with a piece of
art but alfa romeo is focusing less on
the art side and more on that
certification side come with me i'll
explain
[Music]
so this is the service book for my car
and it's basically a paper history of
the life of the vehicle every time i
take my car to the garage they stamp
this book with the work that was carried
out and how many miles were on the clock
and they do that so that when i come to
sell the vehicle there is an authentic
record that i can show a prospective
buyer
even if i didn't have that paper record
there are companies that collect data
from the dmv law enforcement agencies
and insurers to generate a car's history
which prospective buyers can look up
online but what alfa romeo is proposing
is that some of that information could
go directly from the car and onto an nft
each nft is associated to one specific
vehicle and only one the car gators
information directly from the car's
electronic system and recovers all data
on the blockchain the idea is that if
the driver chooses to data like service
history and mileage could be uploaded to
an nft which the driver could then show
a prospective buyer to have the
certainty that you have a data stored
elsewhere non-corruptible not manageable
by the dealer by the fleet by the oem
even that certifies the fact that you
have a certain mileage and nobody can
change that it's something that first
reassures who's buying and of course on
the other side also who's who's selling
now when i spoke to alfa romeo they
couldn't really tell me how much it
would cost to update that nft or what
platform the nft would be hosted on
sorry crypto nerds but while they're not
revealing pricing for now they said
they're working with their blockchain
provider to limit costs and that the nft
might be available at no extra fee for
the customer so could car nfts work well
at the heart of it nfts were designed as
a secure way to store and verify data as
cars are becoming smarter they're
becoming more able to generate and
capture that data for things like
whether the airbags have gone off or
whether there's been sharp braking or
how many times the batteries have been
recharged technically all of that data
could in theory be stored on an nft if
you chose to but what's not clear is
whether this will catch on stalantis who
own alfa romeo told me that nfts would
be rolled out to other cars in the alfa
romeo range and the other brands under
the stellantis flag may follow but in
order for nfts to become widespread
across the auto industry it's likely
that drivers mechanics dealerships and
other automakers are going to have to
learn how to read write store and
transfer those nfts and be willing to
pay for the process and we haven't even
begun to talk about some of the
environmental impact of these nfts so
even if your next set of wheels comes
with its own minted nft i'd hang onto
those paper documents for now
so would you like your next card to come
with an nft let me know in the comments
below and as always if you're interested
in the future of how we might be getting
from a to b then don't forget to
subscribe see you soon